i want to make a quick clarification and
then add more tools in our complex
number toolkit in the first video i said
that if i had a complex number z and
it's equal to a plus
bi
i used a word and i have to be careful
about that word because it you know i i
use it in kind of the everyday sense but
it also has a formal reality to it so
clearly the real part of this of this
complex number is a
clearly that is the real part
and clearly this complex number is made
up of a real number plus an imaginary
number so i just kind of talking in
everyday terms i called this the
imaginary part i called this imaginary
number this imaginary number
the imaginary part but i want to i want
to just be careful there i mean i did
make it clear that if you were to see
the function the real part of z this
would spit out the a
and the function the imaginary part of z
this would spit out and we talked about
this in the first video it would spit
out the number that's scaling the eye so
it would spit out the b
so if someone is talking in in the
formal sense about the imaginary part
they're really talking about the number
that is scaling the i but in my brain
when i think of a complex number i think
of it having a real number and an
imaginary number and if someone would
say well what part of that is the
imaginary number i would have given this
whole thing but if someone says just
what's the imaginary part or they give
you this function just give them the b
hopefully that clarifies things frankly
i think the word imaginary part is badly
named because clearly this is this whole
thing is an imaginary number this right
here is not an imaginary number it's
just a real number it's the real number
scaling scaling the i so they should
call this the number scaling the
imaginary part of z
anyway with that said what i want to
introduce you to is the idea of a
complex numbers conjugate so if this is
z the conjugate of z
the conjugate of z it'd be denoted with
z with a bar over it sometimes it's z
with a little asterisk right over there
that would just be equal to a
a minus bi so let's look how let's see
how they look on an argon diagram
so that's my real axis
my real axis
and then that is my imaginary axis
and then if i have z
this is z over here this height over
here is b
this
base or this length right here is a
that's z
the conjugate of z is a minus bi so it
comes out a on the real axis but it has
minus b as its imaginary part
so just like this
so just like this so this is the
conjugate of z so just to visualize it
it really is the conjugate of a complex
number is really that the mirror image
of that complex number reflected over
the x-axis you can imagine if this was a
pool of water we're seeing its
reflection over here and so we can
actually look at this to visually add
the two con the number
to add the complex number and its
conjugate so we said these are just like
position vectors so if we were to add z
and its conjugate we could essentially
just take this vector shift it up here
do heads to tails
shift it up here do heads to tails so
this right here we are adding z to its
conjugate and so this point right here
this point right here or the vector that
specifies that point is z plus
z's conjugate and you can see right here
just visually this is going to be 2a
this is going to be 2a and we could do
that algebraically if we were to add z
if we were to add z that's a plus bi and
add that to its conjugate so plus
a minus bi what are we going to get
these two guys cancel out we're just
going to have 2a or another way to think
about it and really we're just playing
around with math if i take any complex
number if i take any complex number and
two it i add its conjugate i'm going to
get 2 times
2 times the real part of the complex
number and this is also going to be two
times the real part of the conjugate
because they have the exact same real
part now with that said let's think
about where the conjugate could be
useful
where it could be useful so let's say i
had something like 1 plus
1 plus
2 i
divided by
minus 5 i
4 minus 5x so it's no real obvious way
to simplify this expression maybe i
don't like having this i in the
denominator maybe i just want to write
this as one complex number if i divide
one complex number by another i should
get another complex numbers but how do i
do that
well one thing to do is to multiply the
numerator and the denominator by the
conjugate of the denominator
so 4
plus 5 i
over 4 plus 5 i
and clearly i'm just multiplying by 1
because this is the same number over the
same number but the reason why this is
valuable is if i multiply a number times
its conjugate
i'm going to get a real number so let me
just show you that here so let me let's
just multiply this out
so we're going to get 1 times 4 plus 5i
is 4 plus 5 i
and then
2 i times 4 is plus 8i and then 2i times
5i that would be 10i squared or negative
10.
and then we that will be over now this
has the form a minus b times a plus b so
that's
that's the product of well a plus b
times a minus b is a squared minus b
squared so it's going to be equal to 4
squared which is 16
minus 4 squared oh i didn't have 4 plus
4i here this would be 4 plus 5i
what am i doing 4 plus 5i the same
number over the same number this was a
this was a 10 right over there
this is the conjugate i don't know my
brain must have been thinking in 4. so
obviously i don't want to change the
number 4 plus 5i over 4 plus 5i so let's
multiply this is a minus b times a plus
b so 4 times 4 so it's going to be 4
squared minus 5i squared
4 squared
minus 5i squared and so this is going to
be equal to 4 minus 10. let's add the
real parts 4 minus 10 is negative 6. 5i
plus 8i is 13i
add the imaginary parts and then you
have 16 minus 5i squared well 5i squared
i squared is negative 1. 5 squared is
going to be negative 25. the negative
and the negative cancel out so you have
16 plus 25 so that is 41.
so we can write this as a complex number
this is negative
6 over 41 plus 13 over 41i we were able
to divide these two complex numbers so
the useful thing here is the property
that if i take any if i take any complex
number and i multiply it
any complex number and i multiply it by
its conjugate and obviously the
conjugate of the conjugate is the number
is the original number but i take any
complex number and i multiply it by its
conjugate so this would be a plus bi
times a minus bi i'm going to get a real
number it's going to be a squared
a squared
minus
bi squared difference of squares which
is equal to a squared now this is going
to be negative b squared but we have a
negative sign out here so they cancel
out a squared plus b squared and just
out of curiosity this is the same thing
as the magnitude of our complex number
squared so this is the neat property
this is what makes conjugates really
useful especially when you want to
simplify division of complex numbers
anyway hopefully you found that useful